s
on that in a 3 way race.
All right, let's get a little
bit more serious here and let's
start with a press conference
earlier from 10 Republican
governors, sort of an alliance
of Republican governors laying
out a 10 point plan that they
have all come together to
support to try to control the
border crisis clearly they're
trying to put on a united front
against what they see as
failures from the president
federal administration. Joe
Biden what were the
broad strokes what we heard
today from the GOP governors.
>> So the main take away is
what they're demanding Joe
Biden is number one they want
the wall to be built again they
want Joe Biden to allow the
wall to be built as it stands
right now upwards of 5 million
dollars are being wasted every
single day for the wall to not
be built.
>> American taxpayers are
paying up to 5 mil a day just
to let a bunch a medal.
Bake out in the sun essentially
those contracts are signed the
contractors are being paid but
no work is being done
another thing they want is they
want the remain in Mexico
policy reinstated to remember
just a few weeks ago a federal
judge ordered that it has to be
reinstated while the Biden
administration we've done that
they haven't reached out to
Mexico. There's been no
movement on that front so
they're saying that they're
violating what that federal
judge told they want that to be
taken care of they also want
title 42 to be enforced with
everybody that is the
health rule where once somebody
has encountered at the border,
they get put on a bus and they
get taken right back to Mexico
because of COVID-19 concerns
well, the under the Trump
administration that was being
applied to pretty much almost
anybody who came across under
the Biden administration
they're not doing it with
family units, teenagers kids
that sort of thing so that's
why you see all those crazy
images, a family and it's just
being mass released into the
country. But on buses and
they're getting the fly
wherever they want.
So that the those are those are
kind of a few of the key
points. They also are demanding
that catch and release the end
of that kind of along the same
lines they believe what's
entice in all of these migrants
to come here to America right
now they know and this is true
because I've talked to a bunch
of them over the past several
months, they know they can just
get here and step foot on us
soil. They will have a very
good chance of just being
released into
the country with an or an anti
or a court date several years
down the road because that
there's such a backlog right
now and they can disappear into
the shadows and that is what is
enticing so many of them to
come. The governor say you have
and that immediately you cannot
get these migrants, the prize
or they go through the system
you have to take away the
incentive to come here. They
also pointed out that
they sent a letter to President
Biden 16 days ago asking for a
meeting in person on the
border. And they say president
Biden never responded to that.
>> In the meantime I want to
pick up a one on one the last
points that you made here's a
report from NBC News and you've
already basically confirmed
what they're hearing as well
but just for the audience,
let's listen together to cut 9.
>> After the dramatic surge of
migrants into del Rio Texas
last month the Biden
administration deported some to
Haiti but released the majority
around 13,000 into the U.S. to
wait for asylum cases.
They're still coming now
because of worsening economic
conditions in South America
where some had settled and the
believe he might now be allowed
to stay in the U.S..
>> They believe they might now
be allowed to stay in the U.S.
and it's more than might I mean
it's a very good chance as you
point out bill
and this is what we saw in the
very early days of the border
crisis in the
opening weeks and months of the
Biden administration there were
a bunch of illegal immigrants
entering the country a huge
uptick in
illegal crossings and you had
some journalists go down there
even national journalists for a
couple days
and they were interviewing
illegal immigrants who are
saying we're coming here
because Biden's can lead to
stay some of them chanted his
name some of them had Biden
t-shirts. When it comes to del
Rio and this particular area
and this particular group of
people
from Haiti. They are saying
outright we're coming here
because we think we can stay,
I mean there's not a mystery
right builder they're telling
us explicitly what the messages
that they're receiving based on
Biden policies.
>> There's no mystery at all
and look it's easy to see why
they believe that right they
got cell phones. They've got TV
they've been seeing the images
on TV of of the Fed
just releasing busload after
busload after busload of people
into the public they've seen
all the images of people just
being mass
honestly if I was them I would
think the same thing really the
only people who are being sent
back immediately or a single
adult men.
Or single adult women who are
not pregnant, but it's a family
group it's a couple with a
woman who claims she's pregnant
doesn't have to prove this
claim it or they got a kid with
them. They're going to be
released into the country.
That's just the Biden
administration policy and the
reason why we see so many of
those single adult males
running, it's because they know
if they're caught they're going
to tell a 42 and sent back the
problem is a lot of them get
away its Border. Patrol is just
so overwhelmed right now you
have all these family units
coming across that sucks up
Border Patrol resources, they
have to bring agents to do all
that paperwork and then the
actual agents who are out on
the front lines patrolling.
They get yanked off the front
lines to help out with all that
patrol, so just to put in
perspective for you when that
del Rio situation happen.
Basically every agent in Del
Rio sector about called under
that bridge because they had to
process it
and get them out of there as
fast as possible because it was
such an optics problem well
what happened when all those
agents were down there you know
what happened more than
220 miles of the border in that
sector or less completely on
patrolled who knows how many
drugs came story and they're
going to be people
who died in the United States
and random states Iowa,
Kentucky all across the country
who died us that no overdoses
because of drugs that came
through during that open
window, that's just a fact.
>> Because our resources and
our personnel who by the way
are getting attacked baselessly
with these whipping smears from
the White House.
They all had to go to one place
to clean up an optics problem
for the Biden administration.
And then the number of got a
ways it's just an untold number
of folks and I know that the
estimate is 400,000 known got a
ways this year alone have
entered the United States.
The real number is almost
certainly higher than that and
your point about how this has
an impact not just in border
states explains why there were
10 Republican governors at this
news conference it wasn't just
governor Abbott and governor do
see who are obviously there.
It was also governor Reynolds
from Iowa. Governor Kemp from
Georgia and others. Bill I want
to ask you
about a few other things that
you've reported we talked a bit
about them yesterday I raise
them on the show reports of
people who have been
encountered and have been
detained at the border, not
counting any of the got a ways
and we know that the cartels
and the traffickers and the
Coyote is specifically try to
get people with kids and family
units to all gather in one area
to distract from other areas to
allow you know higher-risk
people to be able to that slip
into the country undetected and
not get detained that is part
of their strategy here and
we've heard that from border
officials now for many months.
But among those who have
gotten caught. There are a
litany of folks even just in
one sector alone, correct who
have been convicted of serious
crimes already in the United
States have been deported and
now they're back again.
>> Look there is no
global database that Border
Patrol has access to or they
can set criminal histories for
people say coming in from
Syria hour or turkey or
something like that the
databases and they're
working with. Yeah, the
databases they're working with
for the most part are here in
the U.S.. So these are people
who have been convicted of
crimes in the U.S. and have
been previously deported.
So then they try to come back.
It used to be
you know if you if you are
repeat offender at the border,
they used to prosecute that
they don't do that anymore.
I if if somebody gets said that
it had a 42
they'll come back that same day
will come back the next day.
I mean they'll try over and
over and over and the federal
government started to kind of
realize that so what they've
been trying to do now is
instead of just tossing them
back across the border, they
put him on an airplane and fly
deep into southern Mexico to
try to make it harder for them
to come back up here but as
we've seen it,
it's not slowing anything down
it's not stopping anybody from
trying. And the crazy thing is
the worst us potentially yet to
come. I mean I'm sure you've
seen all these reports about
the potential 60,000 more
patients making their way
through.
>> He shuns right now and I
correct that Haitians alone not
to count. And if the other you
know many thousands of people
from more than a 100 different
countries right, it's just
60,000 Haitians in that group
coming toward the border.
>> That's correct and where
that number is coming from is
from Panama's foreign minister
she said at the start of the
year. There were a bit once
once Joe Biden took over.
There are 80,000 Haitians who
passed through Panama.
20,000 of turned up at the U.S.
border already so that leaves
about 60,000 left. We're still
trying to move North. So that's
where that number comes from
and there's there have been
videos from top Mexico of those
patients holding protests
demanding to be able to move
North. The Mexican government
does offer resistance in some
areas. But other times they
just let him through and that's
what we saw happen with del
Rio.
>> Pretty breathtaking I
mentioned the 400,000 got a
ways that was the estimate from
the former Border Patrol chief
interviewed on special report
the last 2 nights are you also
hearing because I know it was
reported elsewhere that in
October break is over the
summer supposed to be so hot
that this would sort of calm
down and we would see the
numbers DEP we saw the opposite
the numbers were sky high in
July and August 20 year plus
highs in terms of a border
encounters. They're worried
that in October with the
weather cooling down
that number could grow
substantially perhaps even
double are you hearing that.
>> I've seen the reports that
there trying to prepare for the
potential of 400,000 I mean if
that happened. It I mean
that's just insane, I mean eat.
We've had 200,000 over the last
couple of months and that's
just completely overwhelming.
I will be shocked if it's that
>> I think I think what those
reports are kind of putting
together is just you know the
60,000 Haitians, the cooling
down to the weather.
>> More people saying that
people are being really I think
that's kind of like the worst
case scenario that they're
potentially trying to plan for.
>> If that actually yeah it's
all students. 300,000 to go see
it's not so bad
300,250 1000 a 3rd consecutive
month of 200,000 plus would be
astounding unto itself. So I
sort of wonder they may be
conditioning us to expect
400,000 then claiming victory.
If it's another totally
unsustainable high growth
number allusion last question
for you you tweeted some images
of it looked like guys in in
tactical vest with with long
guns. Powerful weapons where do
you get these images who were
these people and what are the
implications of some of these
images.
>> So those are cartel gunmen
in Roma Texas.
They're involved in human
smuggling we're actually in
Rome right now about a mile
away some of those pictures
were taken. Their cartel gunmen
in Roma Texas, they bring
people across the river and
what you're seeing in those
photos are holding a key
forty-seven's and they're
wearing.
And they are conc being the
Texas National Guard soldiers
on the other side of the river
brandishing their weapons.
This is something that I'm told
has happened multiple times in
recent days and really just
kind of shows how ball the some
of these cartel members are we
often hear.
We often hear that the cartels
are always working at the
border, but very rarely
do we actually get to see them
like that in a picture holding
their weapons just out in the
middle of broad daylight so
tonight we are actually
embedding with the Texas
National Guard here in
in the exact area where this
has been happening so we'll
we'll we'll see we'll see what
happens with that in those
photos, those photos were
courtesy of Texas DPS.
>> I mean it's just so brazen
and they're operating clearly
with what they believed to be
complete impunity are they
ridiculing and taunting the
Texas officials basically
saying we're here and there's
nothing you can do about it.
>> It's not so much they're
saying anything it's defected
to the standing out in the
middle of the Rio Grande with
high powered rifles and just I
look at a Sao no no as they're
bringing people across the
river knowing they're not going
to do anything.
>> And they stay on the other
they they stay on the Mexican
side of the river, so they they
make sure to do that
>> I mean make no mistake if
they were to raise one of their
weapons at one of those
National Guard, they're going
to be blown away. They know
that we know that.
So they're just kind of you
know this kind of causing a
little bit.
>> Yeah, I mean part of me
wonders if if they did raise
the weapon toward our officials
in this country and there was a
firefight you almost wonder if
the federal government would
take the side of our own
officials the way things have
been going. I won't make you
comment on that bill that's
just a side commentary for me
color analysis here on the guy
Benson show
that's allusion on the ground
in Texas Roma Texas at the
border bill you're in betting
tonight with those officials
stay safe keep up the great
work. We'll have you back soon.
>> Will do thanks guy
appreciate it.
>> And just that
high-performance hair every
step of the way it's ver